[Music]
this is a CBS News special report
I'm Norah O'Donnell with Gayle King and
John Dickerson in New York we have
breaking news from North Carolina where
the Reverend Billy Graham has died he
was 99 years old during his life long
ministry Graham became the world's
best-known evangelist he preached in
person to an estimated two hundred and
fifteen million people he also met with
every president from Harry Truman to
Barack Obama William Franklin Graham Jr
was born November 7th 1918 in Charlotte
North Carolina and he committed himself
to Jesus Christ when he was just 16
years old he then began those revival
meetings that he called the Crusades in
the 1940s he was known for his fiery
delivery and a straightforward message
of Christian salvation that attracted
followers from every walk of life the
new medium of television spread his
message even further than that Graham
became friends with several presidents
but he always denied any role in setting
policy he said I don't advise them I
pray with them Billy Graham led his
final crusade in 2005 at that time he
told reporters I look forward to meeting
God face to face he will be buried at
his library in North Carolina next to
Ruth Graham his wife of 64 years I went
to one of his sermons at Camden Yards in
2006 35,000 people he did the altar call
and it was like people rushing a winning
team as they streamed through the aisles
to that altar call at the end of the
sermon he always had such a presence
Billy Graham his words were always very
powerful he would have been 100 November
and quietly advised many presidents
certainly the White House letting know
about them but advise them prayed with
them and was valued by Republicans and
Democrats alike for his spiritual
counsel I went back to Eisenhower our
coverage of the death of Reverend Billy
Graham continues throughout the day on
your local CBS station and our streaming
news network cbsn
and there will be a full wrap-up tonight
on the CBS Evening News with Jeff Glor
many of you will return now to CBS this
morning this has been a CBS News special
report on Gayle King
John Dickerson and Norah O'Donnell CBS
News New York for news 24 hours a day
go to CBS news.com